foreign
[Music]
is the story of one terrible catastrophe
after another
I for once would love to wake up
magically in a better world
[Music]
the world's going to get better
people get their energy from the Sun
[Music]
and have set foot on Mars
cancer has been defeated
yet for every question answered
another one appears
[Music]
that's what you need to know about
Globe doesn't matter at the end of the
century we'll be dead we'll have to miss
it but we'll be smiling in gold-plated
coffins
this is not the life that I envisioned
it to be
these houses on fire is incredibly easy
to negotiate
cannot give up and go home
for one simple reason
we already are home this is our only
home
I think it helps to look at climate
change like a bear
[Music]
the whole planet's been wrestling with
the bear for decades
so far the Bear's been kicking our ass
what if we were able to develop
technology that would allow us to
survive maybe even Thrive you don't know
what's going to happen
it won't go the way you want
it never does
I remember being happy what about now
are you happy now
stop being angry about the past the
future is now
Miami is dangerous your mother's moving
with her sister in Chicago thought you
hated your sister it's true hot out to
hate people these days Marshall
[Music]